royalty sing it if you know the words
this is Hot Tips
[Music]
howdy y'all
I think I'm texting now
I stopped using my turn signal
I took it out there's just a holster
there
I love America I grew up here I went to
John Adams Elementary School shooting
range
hello
a lot of people don't think that trans
women should be allowed to compete in
women's sports
I personally don't think that women
should be allowed to compete in women's
sports
why do we have a category of sports for
people that suck at sports
it's called the Special Olympics
ew
there it is 58 seconds 0.9 the boy is on
fire a great set many punch lines little
local references which I absolutely
loved and then an overall encompassing
great jokes about women sport
the old elephant in the room everybody
wants to say it but no one wants to talk
about it but you're just out here
fighting for your life willing to joke
about anything and we appreciate it uh
the turn signal joke really really I
love it I mean these [__] people out
here are driving me completely [__]
insane it is unbelievable literally the
worst drivers on planet Earth it is the
one catch with living here it's insane
and if you don't think that that means
you're one of them
if you disagree at all you're one of
them you're just in the left lane going
the same speed as the person next to you
with someone flashing their [__]
lights behind you and I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna find each and every one of you
and slowly kill you I'm gonna take you
to the Rainy Street River and I'm gonna
drown you
with my bare hands I've been doing it
don't tell anybody it was me all along
all right Hans a great set how do you
feel uh do you feel Under Pressure
tonight I feel extremely Under Pressure
there's all downside no upside to
beating someone who's only done comedy
once in her life well hold on don't blow
the load I haven't revealed to the
audience exactly who you're going up
against
all right I mean you're really talking
[__] uh you should I think you should
keep the likable face on right now
um uh women don't have their own
division of Comedy like they do in
sports so
um they should though right yeah yeah
hey now uh so Hans anything else
happening interesting in your life this
week that we should know about before
moving on to your competitor yes I was
in Portland recently I was flying my
drone and some Portland woman was like I
did not consent
oh my God Portland is just one of those
dumpster fires right now incredible
worse than Belize
you know it you guys been to Portland
lately it's a real [__] it used to
be lovely
very Progressive City they recently
legalized crime
see what I mean this guy's a [__]
Sharpshooter over here
I've been to Portland a lot of wiggers
there
yeah white guys with dreadlocks and
mixtapes yeah any brown ones that wear
Trump hats
now Portland's like white trash Paris
there's a revolution every weekend and
they don't know which side they're on
like black lives matter I'm like where
are these black lives
also that basketball team that never
wins okay
Hans Kim this is the moment that uh you
have been waiting for uh put the mic
back in the mic stand and um I guess uh
what do we normally do do we keep you on
this stage uh no usually not for these
okay okay well go on Backstage we're
gonna bring you back out in just a
second because the audience decides
tonight whether Hans Kim stays the
regular or not ladies and gentlemen he
kind of leaked something very very
interesting that you may have noticed
his opponent tonight has only done
stand-up comedy one time ever and that
one time ever was last week here
on kill Tony she had signed up many
times over the years seven and a half
years we've known this girl because for
seven and a half years she has been the
girlfriend of Brian redband
[Applause]
she had a set last week and it went so
so so well that I said that she should
battle Hans for regular ship
therefore getting Hans to work a little
harder giving us a little storyline and
you guys get to decide afterwards who's
the regular sound like a deal
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
her second I am ever performing
a 100 kill rate at this point makes some
noise for the Great and Powerful Janice
Min everybody
here we go
all right
[Applause]
hello
um there's a lot of Asian stereotypes
some are true some aren't
but that's for another time
uh here's a new one for you and you can
actually test it out for yourself
so every time an Asian person is
startled or wowed like impressed
don't make this noise
oh
you can you can surprise someone and see
for yourself or impress whatever
speaking of noises
does anyone know who the grape lady is
she went viral on Fox News like this Fox
News segment where she was shot stomping
on grapes really hard and she fell over
and made this funny noise anyway
so she's my safe word now
[Applause]
not not grape lady but the noise she
makes so she goes
that's my noise that's my safe word
Janice men how adorable how likable can
you possibly be
amazing for a second time ever on stage
I love it the setup's a little bit long
but the payoffs were there
and uh very very much fun how do you
feel like that went how do you how do
you feel up here what's been on your
mind this past week since your kill Tony
debut your stand-up comedy debut
uh
honestly I I tried not to think about it
too much
because I would make my heart beat
really fast right yeah that happens it
also made red band's heartbeat very fast
he's been Sweating Bullets all day I
think he's more nervous than I am yeah I
think so red band how do you feel like
that when what are your thoughts it went
good she stumbled on the first joke she
missed a couple of her her uh tags ah
and so I bet she she doesn't even know
that she did the wow the stereotypes
stereotypes oh man someone's getting
beat later you know what I'm saying babe
yeah I'm beating beating it yeah yeah
absolutely
absolutely oh
very surprised
all right let's bring him out Make some
noise for Hans Kim everybody here he is
probably smiling here
still nervous looking at me still
doesn't think he pulled it off
what do you think about this situation
Matthew Broussard it looks a lot like uh
women's sports versus the Special
Olympics yeah it does
it does
I like how kill Tony's doing squid games
now
[Applause]
all right well you guys know how this
goes I warned you you have the fate of
the show in your hands you just a random
group of [__] tourists and locals
that could could change the course of
the history of the show look how scared
Hans is right now he cannot [__]
he cannot hide it so how many of you
have Janice winning this competition
here tonight
whoa whoa that's a lot that's okay
how many of you have Hans Kim
whoa that was close
look how happy he is we can't hide his
emotions thank you guys so much
foreign
noise now
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Janice you Dishonored our family
I put you in under a ridiculously high
pressure situation that no one that's
done stand-up comedy uh once should ever
be in but I look at it as a win-win you
came out funny likable again up for the
challenge so cool it's amazing to see
that's only done comedy twice that's
really impressive yeah
[Applause]
you just got roasted you homo
[Music]
you did better than Uncle laser so
[Applause]
it's been a new running uh thing every
week Uncle laser just gets roasted for
no reason
gotta love it the most hated man in
Austin comedy
Hans how many battles have you won for
your regular ship or no 4-0 undefeated
he refuses to let anybody have a chance
Make some noise for the great Hans Kim
and Janice man everybody
that's a way to get a [__] show
started am I right
all right I pull the name out of the
bucket this is where [__] gets
interesting because we're gonna meet
these people all together